here's what would happen if you were the  only person left on earth  you could go anywhere and do anything  you want but you should probably be more  concerned about your survival  be careful where you seek shelter  because cities would become dangerous  without proper maintenance they'd start  to fall apart pretty quickly even the  country isn't all that safe 400 nuclear  power plants would begin to fail without  human supervision when it comes to food  supermarkets have enough canned food to  last you for decades but if eating  natural is more your style you'd have to  go back to the old ways of hunting and  growing your own vegetable garden  you could drink bottled water and you'd  have thousands of liters to go through  but eventually you'd have to learn how  to purify your own  if you played your cards right you could  easily survive all by yourself  it just might get really lonely so